hey welcome to a new project camp update
so we bought this big piece of land on
our prototyping a more sustainable way
of living not sure how it's going to go
but let's see and in the previous video
you could see us building this clay
pizza oven
which works great makes delicious pizza
but realistically it most of the time
looks like this it's covered under this
yellow canvas to make sure it doesn't
get wet
still a construction site around here we
basically need to clean it up and build
a roof above it which we're gonna do in
this video
but this is also the first time actually
i'm gonna build a structure which raises
some questions like what would be a good
way to build and which kind of local
materials are available around here so
in this video we're going to have a look
into that and we're also going to visit
a few cool workspaces
[Music]
so a nice way to find some true local
materials is to see how did the people
build in the past what kind of materials
were available
and here you would find a lot of clay
wood and granite and you can see this
back in the building materials
so for instance the clay is used for
roof tiles on top of the buildings
underneath they have a structure of wood
to support the tiles also used for
things like doors and after that you
would see just a lot of granite and
granite is used for the walls
for structural strength
and you really see a lot of granite
around here not just houses but also
stairs
roots
water taps
walls churches
bridges
parks
fountains
comfortable couches the ceiling
big piece of art on the wall entire
villages really and it takes a while to
build with this material but it also
lasts long for instance this sculpture
right here is made over 500 years ago
and probably many houses around here as
well
and as you can see like the houses
here behind me they're made from granite
but they look a bit abandoned but what
is really wearing out is the clay the
boot
and the glass but the granite is just
there stays standing for many years
it's very solid and it can also just
survive fires which you have quite a lot
around here
so for instance here you see boot which
burned down with roof tiles on the floor
which actually used to be the roof of
this building
and as you can see now it all collapsed
broke burned down except for the granite
that is still standing
and we actually have a lot of granite on
our land so a really local material i
would actually love to build with it
but to be honest at this point we
wouldn't really know yet what would be a
long-term permanent structure i mean it
would last hundreds of years
and yeah we're just not sure we're still
planning a lot so it would be better to
build something a bit less
permanent more temporary lightweight
so not granite for now
but we actually did find a cool way to
incorporate some granite into a fix for
the pizza oven
one thing that is not really good yet is
this wooden board we put it there in the
beginning more as a placeholder because
we didn't really have a good material
maybe it would last maybe not but turns
out it doesn't the wetness of the clay
bends the whole board and also the heat
is going to wear out to sheet over time
so we're going to replace this board by
something more proper but we didn't
really know what material
until the other day we drove around in
town and we saw something that is just
the perfect fit let me show you
[Music]
alright so we're currently at a super
cool marble place we saw while driving
by because it's right next to the road
and here they just caught a lot of
granite and marble
mainly granite it's also from this
region which is cool and they have a lot
of leftover pieces so we're going to see
if we can find something for the oven
so these are all like leftover pieces
from cutting
not sure what they do with it
also a lot of smaller things
[Music]
beautiful workspace and to cut it
and besides these cutting leftovers they
also just have a lot of old tombstones
and graveyard decoration laying around
like old marble books granite name
boards it's kind of a strange setting
having this laying around right next to
the road
yeah anyway we found a cool piece for
ourselves that we could use as a counter
just needs to be cut it into the right
size
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so we're not going to build with granite
but we still need to build something so
another material you can build with
is wood
and wood you actually see surprisingly
little being used around here for
construction
um
if you see it it's in ways like this so
it becomes from the outside it looks
like a stone house once actually used a
lot of wood however it is more
vulnerable because it could catch fire
and wood could rot away
so that sounds as a bit less of a
permanent structure but even this you
don't find too much of that around and i
think the reason why people don't really
build with wood too much is because
the rock keeps the heat outside in the
summer the cold outside in the winter it
doesn't burn down so i think for a lot
of people it feels superior
however nowadays people don't really
build with granite that much but it's
all replaced by concrete so they would
really use cement which is a cheap quick
way to just replicate the big granite
rocks
but we don't like samantha so we're
gonna
build something with wood now we have
some wood on our land
but not really because the land burned
down four years ago so everything you
see is trees that are max four years old
like here so they're way too tend to
actually build with
i think we might have like two or three
big trees on the land but besides that
it's all this which is going to be 210
to build so we need to find some bigger
trees so we're currently at the local
sawmill where they cut trees into things
you can use for timber or planks
to construct things with and the place
is kind of cool so let me show you this
building right behind here where they
cut everything
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and finally we also need something for
the roof so uh we found a bunch of roof
tiles when we were cleaning up the ruins
on our land and even though they all
burned down
uh the rooftops still somewhat usable
some of them some not but either way
they're now on a structure that is half
collapsing half burnt uh rotting away
so we need to take care of that because
they might fall on our hat so we're
gonna see
if we can try to reuse as much as we can
from the old ruins
and then carefully take them off
however we don't have the right tools
and equipment ourselves to do it like a
scaffolding so we have some local guys
that can help us out all right so now we
have a few guys helping out to go on the
roof of the workspace to take off the
roof tiles the ones that are still good
and the bad ones to take them down so
they don't fall on our head later
to be honest goes a bit rougher than
expected uh different selection criteria
of what is a good tile and what is not
[Music]
i work
[Music]
to be honest it was quite scary seeing
them that easy on the roof i mean it
seems so fragile half burned down and
ready to collapse
here to hold up the part he's sitting
you basically have one half
beam hanging
i guess we just need to have some feet
[Music]
so
[Music]
so we have rooftops now
[Music]
we have a few hotels
we have a safe roof
i can't believe the guy was just
standing on there
they said it was good
looks good it looks very good
so we have the tiles here now in base
camp they are a bit dirty so before they
go up to the shade roof we will just
give them a good clean
[Music]
do
[Music]
all right so we now have the wood and
the roof tiles we can build which smells
super nice we also made a 3d model
as you can see here
it's a pretty basic structure
basically just to hold the roof dials
but we're going to build the whole
structure in another video but not the
next video because the next video we're
going to talk about our problems or
challenges and we're also going to do a
q a so we're going to answer the
questions you guys have so if you have
any questions make sure to post them in
the comments of this video
we'll read them and we'll answer them
next week
thanks for watching see you in the next
update